okay so let's try this one
marshmallow 2007
from iran we'll go c4 this time
knight f6 will go g3
g2
knight c3 and uh i'm going to go for e4
next
the old but munich system
which is not bad
it's an it's an opening oh that's
interesting
okay i'll go f3 usually i don't want to
allow
the the bishop for the knights
because that would mean i have one less
piece fighting for the d4 square
a6 now
this is a bit weird to have the bottom
f3 usually you have the polymer h3
or when you're black h6
so let me go b3 now preparing d4
because i do like the
of course i i do like the the botanic
structure but
getting emergency structure should also
not be bad
and now after these exchanges i have a
safe
i have a safe little advantage
queen d7 is a solid move but it feels a
bit aimless
oh there is a concrete aim to go for
for b5 that was a bit
that was a bit lazy my part
bishop h3 not particularly concerned
about that
he wants to exchange my bishop i'm fine
that bishop had
quite few prospects anyway e5
this one i don't like for my opponents
because
the bishop was annoying on d4
and it's tempting to kick it away
but i think it comes into higher price
now the
opponent d6 is extremely weak and
i have a juicy square for the knights on
d5 so
here um
rk2 was obviously to go rook t2 later on
put pressure on d6
now i do have a possible tactic with
rook to d2
but my opponent will go knight takes b6
i would go rook that
takes d6 and he will go knight takes c4
point is if i then take the
queen on c6 93 check happens
we'll then take the queen and take
the rook later on which means that i
can't do that
so i'll go knight d5 instead threatening
a pretty juicy fork on e7 which my
opponent
missed and that's that's the game right
there
um i always advocate for my opponents to
play
to play fairly slowly in this game in
these games to try and learn
um obviously you're gonna have problems
with time
then sometimes but um i think it's a
better learning experience